gipso's polling exclusive to global news
finds just over a bare majority or 52
percent of canadians are in support of
attacks on the unvaccinated and while a
significant portion don't share that
view fully two-thirds of canadians want
further restrictions on unvaccinated
people what it signals is something very
similar that we're seeing across the
board when it comes to covid vaccines
lockdowns just general
attitudes that people have about what's
going on is that there's a lot of split
opinion one of the things that we saw at
the start of this whole process and we
saw for uh consistently for a pretty
long time was that people were pretty
united on a lot of these issues and what
we've seen over the space of
particularly omicron is that people are
becoming more divided so 52 saying yes
um we should probably be taxing but that
means 48 of the population is on the
other side of this
who feels that we should be doing more
taxing tend to be uh tend to be people
who are older uh tend to be people who
are better better educated and probably
buying more into the science of what's
going on with uh the uh the coveted
crisis that we're going through and
particularly people who live in places
like quebec
but even as you go across the country
opinions are pretty divided just about
everywhere i think what we're seeing uh
in the data is that there is some uh
relationship to what's actually
happening in a particular province at
any one time so for example if you're in
ontario and you're just still you know
in a lockdown situation or any other
place that's in a lockdown situation you
tend to be a little bit more supportive
but what we're talking about here is you
know three four five point differences
we're not talking 20 30 40 50 point
differences people are are
pretty consistent across the country on
most of the issues that relate to covet
these days it's not really driven by
geography as much as it's been driven by
people's experience yeah 52 percent is
usually the when you start into
something when you give people the first
the first notion of of of uh what it is
people are you generally a little bit
curious
um and a little softer in terms of their
opinion because they have no experience
with uh what the implications might be
so i think 52 is probably the high water
mark on this and and i would expect that
over time if people do actually see uh
some sort of a tax coming into place
that support for the tax will likely
soften not increase
half of canadians blame unvaccinated
people for the pandemic not being over
and while almost three-quarters of
canadians would welcome a vaccinated
person into their homes no questions
asked just 36 would do the same for an
unvaccinated person the public
tends to have a view that people should
have their movement restricted
as a result of being unvaccinated so
it's not that we
the people really support doing things
strongly support doing things
specifically to the unvaccinated it's
it's more that they believe that the
space in which the unvaccinated are
allowed to operate and come into contact
with other people should be more
restrictive so for example further
restrictions on the unvaccinated 67
percent taxing them 52
uh but
people are quite um when they talk about
the social way of dealing with it um are
fairly more reasonable in terms of their
approach they're a bit more
accommodating but when it comes to
coming into contact with them in their
own personal homes
absolutely people have difficulty
letting in somebody into their home
that's unvaccinated even doing things
for example like a rapid test in order
to let people uh go into somebody's home
there's a lot of people who who say that
that's not even enough so it's it's
really restricting their access to other
people that they might become
they might come into contact rather than
doing something specifically to people
who are unvaccinated well you know
everything eventually becomes political
and and this is a health issue that's
become overwhelmingly political but one
of the things that we're seeing about
politics these days is it tends to
divide people more so uh 21 of the
people that we interviewed said they
would end a friendship with somebody
based on their vaccine vaccine status so
that means people who are probably on
one side or the other side of this issue
uh more strongly but one in five uh say
they would be prepared to end a
friendship over this